bu iş basma pusulamı nasıl yer almamız
gerektiği ile ilgili kendi hikayemden
yola çıkarak sizlere destek olmaya
çalışacağım halihazırda Şu an bir özel
üniversitenin bölüm başkanlığını
yürütüyorum rektör danışmanıyım
erkeğinin yapay zeka ve bilgisayar
bilimleri laboratuvarını araştırmacı
sayım Türkiye'de henüz işlenmemiş
olanlar da çok korku patentlerini
projelerin var aynı zamanda 2020 yılının
Yapay Zeka alanında farkındalık yöneten
Lider öldürme sahibim ve tüm bunların
yanında Yapay Zeka politikaları
Derneği'nin Yapay Zeka alanındaki
danışmanı papirüsler Derneği'nin Başkan
yardımcısıyım her biri birbirinden güzel
için bu salçaların arkasında hocam an
Bir Hayal Kırıklığı kocaman bir
başarısızlık hikayesi ve bu başarısız
sevmeyiz bir kere şurada netleştirelim
hayat hiç kimseye acil
daha çok iyi liselerden mezun olmadım ya
da böyle bir imkanın hiçbir zaman olmadı
aslında bir öğretmen anne babanın
çocuğuydum ve hayatın Aslında başlarken
bir sıfırdan Daha ziyade 10-0 yeni
başlayan çocuklarından bir tanesiydim
ailenizdeki sorunların sizi çok açtı
dönemlerde bunlarla mücadele
edemediğiniz dik açacağız tekrar vardı
kitaplardır hayatım boyunca üç tane
annem oldu çünkü annem maalesef 99
2009'da geçtiğimiz sene geçirdiği beyin
ameliyatları sonrasında her seferinde
karakteri bambaşka bir insan olarak
karşıma çıksın üç farklı anne idare
etmek bir çocuğun çeşitli Hayat
hikâyesinde oldukça kırılgan anları
ifade eder ilk tercih ilk hayattaki
dönüm noktasını sanıyorum Yıldız Teknik
Üniversitesi matematik Bölümü'nü tercih
ederken yaptım ve bizim dönemimizde
sizlerin zamanındaki kadar şanslı
bu Çünkü sınav sonuçlarımızı ancak
tercihlerimiz ile beraber görebiliyorduk
yani tercihlerimizi Yaparken butun bazı
büyük için hissetmediğimiz göre yedi ya
da 9 tane tercih yapacaktı buna bundan
sonra hayatımı şekillendirecek bir karar
verdim lüks al değil sayısal karar verip
sayısallara sayısal değerlere güvenme
Kendime şunu sordum beş yıl sonrasının
türkiye'sine ya da 500 parçanın
dünyasına baktığında ne yazarsam Benim
daha çok işime yarar ne yazarsam
gerçekten olmak istediklerimi
gerçekleştirebilir Hayallerinin peşinden
koşabilirim bu sorunun cevabını iki
temel meslekte buldum biri doktorluk to
Öteki de matematiktir birbirinden
alakasız gibi gözüken tercihleri
sıraladım Hatta o dönemlerde üçüncü
tercihim Trakya Tıp Fakültesi 4.
tercihim Yıldız Teknik matematik
bölümüydü bizim zamanımızda ol
da maksimum puan 520 civarı Ben 494 puan
alarak Aslında 405 puanlık trafik Trakya
tıp fakültesine değildi 492 sürüp Yıldız
Teknik Üniversitesi'ne yerleştim Hatta o
dönemlerde yok etrafı larda bulunmada
dair O zaman gittiğim derslerden ve
arkadaşlarından baskı gördüm ama benim
bir daha üniversite sınavı ile ya da yok
uğraşacak gücüm yoktu bunu Okuyacağım
artık dedim matematik bölümünü ilk
girdiğim git herhalde hayatımın en komik
filmlerinden bir tanesi 7 60 kişi
birbirini tanımayan farklı noktalardan
gelen ve okuduğumuz şeyi bize anlatılan
şey kesinlikle anlamayan 60 kişi
yaklaşık iki ay harcadıktan sonra ne
kadar Tual hiçbir Hocanın söylediği
Hiçbir şey anlamıyoruz sanki ya bir
Fransız ya onlar Fransız ortada bir
tercüman yok ve bizler bizi anlatılanlar
konusunda kalem dahi oynat
12 ayın sonunda Bu arada 60 kişinin
tamamı aynı sıkıntı çekiyoruz Bu böyle
olmayacak Hani bırakıp geri dönüp
Üniversiteyi de hazırlanacağız Çünkü biz
dönemin sınav döneminde öğrencileriyiz
işte hemen sesle var Hemen gelirse var
İkisi de aynı anda uğraşmak gerçekten
hiç yakın alır değil Ne yapalım
sınıflardan bir sorunum niye biz bunu
yaşıyoruz en çok mu akıllı çok mu
problemli miyiz acaba yakaladık birkaç
kişi yani hikaye oldu Biz hiçbir şey
anlamıyoruz yediklerimizden kelimesi
kelimesinin yazacağız ama yazamıyor Uz
bile önceki gülümsedi yakaladığımız
arkadaş biraz daha sabret biraz daha
sabredin bir 15-20 gün daha Samet'i bir
sabah kalktığınızda her şey sizin için
berraklaşır acak ve anlamadığınız
zannettiğiniz her şeyi anlamaya
başlayacaksınız Aslında çok tuhaf
gelmişti kimsenin elinde sihirli değnek
falan yok iki aydır anlamadığımız şey
nasıl iki hafta
bak bak kalkacağız ve anlayacağız Ama
gerçekten söylediği gibi oldu yaklaşık 2
hafta sonra sanki biri elinde toz bezi
beynimizdeki bütün o karanlık noktaları
silmiş temizlenmiş ve biz her şeyi anlar
teori sıfatlar hale gelmiştik burada
birinci nokta beyin zorlanmaya alışkın
bir organ ve biz belli bir eşik değeri
ne kadar onu zorladığı mızda hiç
yapamayacağımızı ve asla
başaramayacağını düşündüğümüz bir yerde
bu umutsuzluğa kapılmaz yapamayacağım
yapamıyorum sözcüklerin adına sığmazsa
keşif değerini Aşan Beynimiz kendini
adapte ediyor Çünkü insan adaptasyon
yeteneği yüksek canlılardan bir tanesi
60 kişinin girdiği Yıldız Teknik
Matematik Bölümü her sene iki ya da üç
mezun vermesiyle övünür bu sene 55 kişi
mezun olduk şu an herkes dünyanın dört
bir tarafında çok kıymetli yerlerde çok
o işlerle uğraşıyorum üniversiteden
mezun olduktan sonra yüzüme çarpan duvar
kadından matematikçi olmaz ifadesiydi
Bunu bana söyleyen yöneticimi onu çok
yakın zamanda koltuğundan edebileceğim
söylemiştim ve kısa süre sonra da bu
gerçekleşti Çünkü önümüze konulan
tabuları toplumsal dayatmaları kabul
etmek zorunda değilsiniz o da atmaların
dayandı bir mantık matematiksel mantık
yoksa geçmişten gelen öğrenilmiş
tiklerle sizi yönlendirir olarsa
sendikacı almayayım Kısa bir süre sonra
daha Facebook'un bile olmadığı bir
dünyada 2 3 arkadaşlar birlikte bir
önünüzde direkt şirketleri ürün satmaya
karar verdik tabi kapısını çaldığımız
şirket gülmekten yerlere yaptık hani
benim bu kadar yıllık deneyimim var Sen
topladığın verilerle bana niye üretmem
gerektiğini nerede satmam gerektiğini mi
anlatacaksın biraz zorlandık eğitim
camiasına girdik Ben abi
O çocuk o dönemde Aslında yeni başlayan
bir startupfon ortağı haline gelmiştim
hayatta muhakkak risk alıp ve aldığımız
riskler de öylesine düşün ki hiç
kalkmayacak mışçasına düşün ve kalkmayı
başarının Çünkü bu yaşadığınız travma
hayatta bir daha hiçbir şeyin sizi
yıkamayacağı gösterir ve vazgeçtiğiniz
şeyler için yeniden başlayabilme
enerjiniz olduğunu unutmayın Şirket çok
başarılı bir noktaya gelmişti 2009
sabahı annemin geçirdiği krizde
karşılaştım yavru kaybetme tehlikesiyle
karşı karşıya kaldım şirketteki bütün
isteklerini devrettim benim tek annemizi
da ona bakmaya karar verdim Bu arada
yarım bıraktım yüksek lisans vardı ama
kariyer planları tamamiyle altüst
olmuştum olsun Sağlıklı İslam
düşünebiliyor Sam enerjim varsa ve
hayata dair yapabileceklerinden
unuttuysam her zaman yeniden her zaman
sıfırdan başlayabilirsiniz Çünkü
sıfırdan sonrası birden sonra
ya ondan sonra mıyız Biz ise İstanbul
Üniversitesi'nde akademisyen ettik aldım
akademisyenliği yedi yıl boyunca
İstanbul Üniversitesi'nde devam ettirdim
o dönemde çok çeşitli alanlarda Örneğin
çocuk suçluluğuna yönelik Matematiksel
modelleme projeleri yaptım ya da 2016
yılında üstün yetenekli sporcuları
tespit edilebilmesi ile ilgili
giyilebilir cihaz tasarımı patentleri
gerçekleştirdik çok güzel bir ekiple
yani dünyanın şu anda sporda yapay
zekayı konuştu bir dönemde Ben 2016
yılında bunların paketlerine sahip
özellikle spordan anlamak takımda
tutmuyorum bu hayat hikayesi 7 yıllık
İstanbul Üniversitesi'nde sonlandırmaya
Karar verdiğim gibi tekrar Bir dönüm
noktasına girdi Çünkü hayat Sosyal biri
değilim maalesef hayat bana okumuz çok
Adil davranmadı çok destekleyici bir
anne babam olmadığı için hasta
kitaplardan başka bir kardeş
O başka çok fazla bir dünyam olamadık
Ama muhakkak benim yaptığım yapmayın bir
hobi edinin ve çalışıyor olsanız bile
muhakkak 2 el ile çalınabilecek bir
müzik aleti çalım Çünkü beyninizin her
iki yarım küresini deaktive edeceği için
öğrenme süreçlerini geliştirecek
İstanbul Üniversitesi'nden ayrılmaya
karar verdim gibi herkes bunu şunu
söyledim çok kötü aptallık yapıyorsun
burada ayrılma hikayemde şöyle ya
pazartesi sabah kalktım şey değildir
çünkü işim benim hobimdir severek
yaparım İşimi hala seviyorsam Kurumu
değiştirme vakti gelmiştir dedim o
Pazartesi günü çeşitli üniversitelerin
rektörleri ile görüştüm akşam bir kağıda
Lütfen bu da bir kıralım noktası
unutmayın bir kağıda benim için ne
önemli çıkardım alt alta yazdım
yanlarına ne kadar önemli olduğuna dair
sayılar verdim sonra o sayıları kapatıp
her üniversite için
o maaş kaç puan ve puanlar vardı
sonrasında sayıları çarpıp topladım en
nihayetinde bir üniversitenin sayısal
değil çok büyük çıktı Salı günü istifamı
verdim çarşamba günü eşyalarımı topladım
Perşembe günü uğraştırdı başladım
dolayısıyla risk alın risk alabilmek
sizi güçlü kılar Ama bu riski alırken
duygusaldır size üzerine değil yoksa
ayakları yere basan şekilde hareket edin
sonrasında Amerika macerası başladı emin
olun Hayatımın en zor deneyimlerinden
bir tanesiydi yurt dışına çıkacaksınız
İstanbul erken yaşlarda yapın belli bir
yaştan sonra emin olun e var Kadıköy
erken yaşlarda yapmak bazı
alışkanlıkları kazanmamız konusunda Size
yardımcı olacaktır Amerika'ya ilk
gittiğimde o zaman ki posta kum
elektrik-elektronik ve bilgisayar
mühendisliği bölümünde ydi ilk 19'un
kendimden nefret ettim ve bir köşe
koltuğunda battaniyenin altında otur
Ya ben Akdeniz insanıyım benim için
sıcak hava 23 derecedir onlar için sıcak
hava on dereceydi Dolayısıyla Bu on
derecede hayata tutunmaya çalışıyorsunuz
götürdüğünüz her şeyi yazdık kıyafet
mutsuzsunuz yemekleri size benzemiyor
kültürleri size benzemiyor 19 günün
sonunda Yapacak bir şey yok Bir
dönmeyeceksin o zaman alış bakalım dedim
Benden önce gitmiş olan arkadaşlarımla
konuştum da 19 mu sürdün sürdü sadece
biz kırk gün uğraştık kırk gün sızladı
40000 geri dönmek istedik Sen yine çok
şanslıyım misin dediler O seni dönerken
bir hocam benden bir emaneti bardağı
almamı istemiştim bardak ve sevdiğim bir
hatıra türüdür kendi kendime kendime de
biraz daha diye düşündüm zorlarım ki
gitmediğim üniversitenin niye bardağını
alayım ki Belki bir gün bu dediğimin o
gün kabul olacağını bilemezdim 2019
yılının başında emakin açtığı bir sır
bu ama sınava girerken aynı aşamada da
benim alacaklar ama elimden geleni
yaptım Hatta beni almayacaklarını o
kadar emindim ki Şah Üniversitesi
İstinye Üniversitesi ile anlaşma
imzalamıştı mewo beni Aldılar eve iki
apayrı bir maceraydı orada olmak ikinci
defa Amerika'ya gitmek yeni bir kültür
elinden ahlaklı olmak çok zor gelmedi
fakat yurtdışında senelerce yaşayınca ve
yalnız yaşayabildiği ailenizden ayrı bir
şey ineceğim Hayatta hiçbir şeyin hiç
kimsenin sizi yıkamayacağı
öğreniyorsunuz çünkü gittiğinizde o
kadar gibi vuruyorsunuz ki yukarıdan
başka gidecek yer olmadığını keşfe
diyorsunuz döndükten sonra Türkiye'de
özellikle Yapay Zeka alanında çalışmalar
yapmaya başladım ve Henüz daha geleceğin
meslekleri konusu konuşulmaz Ken 2019'da
radikal bir kanal kararlı meslektaşına
birlikte geleceğin meslekleri kitabını
yazdık başta Akademi camiye
bu üzere pek çok insan Tepki gösterdim
Olur mu böyle saçma sapan şey dediler
hayatım olurum ilginç cümleleri ezip
geçmek ne oldu Bunları kesip geçerken
ruh hiç yaralanmadı mı Evet çok üzüldüm
Çok Yaralandım pek çok noktalar oldu Ama
hayatta her zaman düştüğünüzde
kalkabileceğimi biliyorsunuz hiçbir şey
zor değildir Sadece üzerine yeterli
görüntüde vakit ayırmadığı mız şeyler
vardır brayer bir şey size çok zor
geliyorsun lütfen anne ve babalarınızı
dönüp Okuma yazmayı nasıl öğrendiğinizi
hatırlatmalarını isteyeyim ya da çarpım
tablosunu nasıl ezberlediğiniz Bunlar o
dönemin O zaman yaşadıklarınızın en
büyük zorluklar Iy dış Şimdi sizin için
son derece basitler Aslında zor gelen
her şey bir daha tekrar edeceğim
üzerinde yeterli garajda
bu ayırmadık larımız ayırmadık larımız
Kendinizden vazgeç işlerimiz bu ne kadar
başarılı bir hayat hikayesi anlattın hiç
ve başarısızlıkların yok şu zamana kadar
10-15 Yurtiçi yurtdışı başarılı projeyi
kapatmış Sam 122 adet red ve başarısız
projem var Hepsini birbirinden daha çok
seviyorum çünkü bana en çok şeyi
öreceğim başarısızlıkları mı oldu
başarılarınız dan şey öğrenemezsiniz
Başarılarını sadece sizin kendinize olan
güveninizi ilk Hatta jilet gibi hale
getirir Ama başarısızlıklarını öyle mi
verdikleri dersleri asla unutamazsınız
verdikleri dersleri unutmadınız gibi
nasıl bir daha aynı hatayı düşmeyeceğini
öğrenirsiniz bütün Hayallerimi
gerçekleştirdim mi Tabii ki hayır Hayal
kırıklıkları insanlar içindir hayal
kırıklığı yaşadığınızda kırıklıklarını
yapıştırmaya çalışmayın yeni Hayaller
Grup Yeni Hayaller kurabilecek güce
Ben de bir kere Şundan emin olun Eğer
bir hayalimiz için elinizden gelen
herşeyi yaptıysanız Ama buna rağmen
gerçekleşmiyorsa bebek ki de yenisini
korumalısınız bırakıp gitmeyi
bilmelisiniz hani şöyle ise duvarlarına
yazdığımız meşhur bir laf var Bırak
gitsin dönerse senindir dönmezse zaten
senin hiç olmamıştır hayallerimizde
böyle yeterli görülse de çaba sarf
ettiğimiz de bir gün onları ulaşabiliyor
Sak zaten Bizimdir çalışmadığımız da
zaten bizim olmamıştır Bir Hayal
kırıklıklarım başarısızlıklarım hayatta
en çok sevdiklerim en çok gurur
Duyduklarım kimse sizi başarısız
olacaksınız misk alamayacaksınız diye
bir şeyler söylersin üzerinde durmayın
Eğer bir şekilde devam edebiliyorsak
öğrene biliyorsak ilerleye biliyorsak
merak ediyorsak hayal
Bu da en güzelleri başarısızlıklar en
güzelleri resimler en güzelleri benim
hayat hikayem de kimsenin risk almadığı
dert haplardan bahsetmediği bir dönemde
Risk almak istersem kurmak vardı şimdi
dökelim İsyan liklar en çok sevdiğim
ünvanı doktorum vardı çünkü o unvan
alabilmek için bir bir buçuk ay bir ofis
masasında yapmak zorunda kaldım yani
dönüp baktığınızda bütün anlatılan süslü
ve parıltılı hikâyelerin arkasında ciddi
anlamda ya bir Picasso tablosu gibi
kargacık burgacık eciş bücüş Hayatlar ya
da çok büyük dramlar Var Hayat hiç
kimseye Adil değil baştaki noktaya geri
dönelim bu adaletsizliğin içerisinde Ya
hepimiz kendimiz tırmalamak pürüz
kendiniz ilerlemek zorundayız bu
adaletsizlik ailemizden gelebilir
mesleğimiz den Gelebilir işimizden
gelebilir önce kendinizle Barış'ın önce
ne olur
bu devam edebileceğinizi üst denizde
kalkabileceğimi Zeyna'nın Her şey
insanlar için teşekkür ederim